attention ces petites choses sur
métallique peut vite devenir addictives
car même les débutants arrive facilement
à faire quelques pas les claquettes une
danse festive le symbole des comédies
musicales qui se pratique à tout âge
j'ai regardé un film qui happy feet
classement délaissée et je vais les voir
au cinéma je suis sorti j'ai dit maman
je faire des claquettes et depuis bas
qui part et et je continue toujours
qu'est ce qui est plaisant avec les
claquettes basse à des fous je fais que
de la danse classique donc les
claquettes en découlent vous faites par
ba da da da da da da da da le professeur
n'a pas attendu les répétitions pour
préparer les chorégraphies cette année
le thème du spectacle c'est le désordre
et c'est zazie je ne produis des
claquettes qui jouera les trouble fête
on va créer un désordre avec tes
interventions de
deux mâts de ma fille qui en fait et
anthony de danse classique au départ et
qui s'est trompé de numéro changement de
musique et d'univers avec le flamenco
ici en tant qu'un mariage osé avec les
claquettes
les danseurs se lancent des défis une
sorte de compétition entre les
chaussures à talons et des claquettes
chacun donne son tempo et la technique
elle est très différent quand vous avez
vu dans le flamenco à l'est on est très
très très connecté sur théret mais les
claquer et ils sautaient c'est une autre
façon de toucher le sol absolument
différent et donc ça là c'est la joie et
c'est le jeu le rythme est très soutenu
les stagiaires doivent enchaîner une
répétition en fonction des danses qu'ils
ont choisi pour le spectacle c'est assez
intense
on est un peu stressé parce qu'il ya que
trois jours et du cou
il faut bien écouter les corrections
savoir tout de suite corrigé
les petites erreurs et pensez à tous
donc il faut rester concentré tout au
premier abord pas le droit ou désordre
dans la répétition de bruno agati une
centaine de stagiaires doit s'accorder
se placer au bon endroit et réaliser le
mouvement juste une véritable petite
armée au service de la danse le désordre
un thème qui a inspiré le chorégraphe je
fais arrivé mi chou avec ses michettes
en plein milieu de l'ordre je fais
arrivée amanda lear avec son ambiguïté
entre l'homme et la femme et le travesti
je fais voilà c'est le désordre
qui peut déranger parfum de société en
ordre ou en désordres
les stagiaires vont répéter plusieurs
heures par jour jusqu'à vendredi quoi
qu'il arrive tous devront être prêt pour
le spectacle final